you are a first-time podcaster this is
grounded with Louis Theroux
and presumably this was your idea you
just got four I'm going crazy here I
want to work well like millions of
others when that when the pandemic hit
all my plans had to change so the
conversation turned to well what can you
do from your home and we had this idea
of interviewing people who I've always
wanted to speak to people with a profile
people who I think I'd have a good
conversation with and doing it down the
internet and kind of comparing notes
during this difficult time I think is a
positive as well yeah and now Jon Ronson
that one's already gone out who else do
we have to look forward to I just did an
interview with a friend of yours who
asked to be remembered to you by the way
Helena Bonham Carter Oh something about
are you still singing which she said you
would understand it is true she's very
keen on my singing she sent me a big bag
of kind of witch's brew that I could
make and then you drink it and you can
sing and I nearly drank it and then I
thought I don't really trust her
anything strong in her one of her most
famous incarnations so she has Wizarding
powers but I think this is the first
time you've interviewed sort of your
peers in a way I suppose it's a look
it's the first time I've ever done an
interview that isn't in a real location
in the sense of it isn't part of a live
encounter normally I either go into
someone's home I stand up in the kitchen
have a coffee we spend a couple of hours
talking about this and that but all
we're in motion doing something
someone's doing their job on a porn set
out in the wilds of Idaho or in a
hospital wherever it may be these are
much more conversations in which the
star of the conversation is really just
the chat bit like dare I compared myself
to you Graham
what you do back off look at you yeah
you get back to ranches
I want you back in the field
[Music]